what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the walls in attack on
Titan and the real reason why these
three massive structures were built in
the first place
at first we are told that the walls
exist as a way to protect the last
remnants of humanity from the Titans but
we later learned that this is not the
case and the walls were built for an
entirely different reason altogether not
only that but everything from the way
that the walls were created to the names
that were given to the walls Maria rose
and Sheena is deeply rooted in the
secret history of the LDN people a
history that Humanity behind the walls
didn't even know existed in this video I
will explain everything we know so far
about the three giant walls and the real
reason why they were built in the first
place I will also discuss all of the
still unsolved mysteries about the walls
including how and why each wall got its
name Before we jump into it I want to
give a quick thank you to black desert
for sponsoring this video
black desert is an online MMORPG that
I've been playing for over six months
and I can say with confidence that it
really stands out from the competition
you can build your own custom character
from scratch there are 18 diverse
classes to choose from and the character
creation system is so detailed it's
crazy
black desert includes real-time action
based combat which includes fast paced
combos and diverse weapons and fighting
styles that make it an epic gaming
experience the graphics are beautiful
don't take my word for it you have to
see it for yourself
and as a huge fan of fantasy I was
hooked right away the game is constantly
being updated in a brand new class known
as the shy class has just been
introduced into the game the shy are
adorable in their the first class that
excels in support abilities and life
skills - I used the flooring a giant
boomerang as their main weapon of combat
and the small size of the shy makes them
very fast and nimble when evading and
attacking enemies this new class is a
ton of fun to play try it out for
yourself just click the link in the
description for a free 7-day trial and
you'll see exactly why I love this game
any player who reaches level 50 with the
7 day free trial
will receive a game pass to play the
game forever if you enjoyed the attack
on titan content on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
abroad don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell and in case you
don't know we are on twitter and
instagram at anime uproars so give us a
follow for all the latest updates there
will be some manga spoilers in this
video about the walls so please proceed
with caution you have been warned after
we learned the truth about Aaron's
basement and the world beyond the walls
we also get a glimpse at the hidden
history of the walls and the LDN people
in general nearly two thousand years ago
an ancestor of the LD ins called Amir
frits somehow gained the power of the
nine Titan shifters and she used that
power to eventually form a great LD an
empire that ruled over much of the world
after he mears death the nine Titan
shifter powers were held by various LD
and noble families and these families
used them to fight each other over power
and influence about 100 years prior to
the beginning of the attack on titan
story the 145th LD and king called karl
fritz decided to abandon the continent
that had been dominated by the alien
Empire and he relocated as many LD ends
as he could to the island of paradise
there he used the founding titan power
to construct the three walls called
Maria Rose and Sheena and he also used
the Titan power to erase all memories of
the outside world from all the LD ends
on the island in this way the 145th king
isolated himself from all the war and
suffering on the continent allowing the
LD ends that he took with him to live in
relative peace the king allegedly used
millions of wall Titans in order to
construct the inner core of the three
walls and these Titans are currently
dormant because the Titans need sunlight
to function properly and the surface of
the walls is preventing the Titans from
moving the walls themselves are around
fifty meters in height and although they
are very strong it is possible to damage
the surface of the walls as the female
Titan did when she was trying to climb
wall Sheena King Karl Fritz threatened
the outside world that if anyone tried
to interfere with the affairs of the
island he would
the millions of wall Titans from within
the walls and have them flatten the
entire world it is important to note
that by some estimates just over half a
million wall Titans total would be
enough to fill the three walls so it is
possible that the claim that there are
millions or tens of millions of wall
Titans is just an exaggeration designed
to maximize the power of the Kings
threat after King called Fritz abandoned
the continent the LDN empire collapsed
and the content was taken over by the
rival nation of Marlay it was only after
the walls were already constructed that
the marlins began oppressing the
audience who remained on the continent
and as a form of punishment they would
ship some of the audience off to the
island of parodies and used the Titans
serum to transform them into mindless
Titans these mindless Titans then began
roaming around the outer edges of the
island and they were eventually
encountered by anyone who ventured
beyond wall Maria because the 145th King
used the founding Titans power to erase
all memories of the outside world from
the LD ends on the island the people
living behind the walls began to think
that they were the only humans left
alive in the world because the rest of
humanity was destroyed by Titans
understandably they also came to think
that the reason that the walls were
built in the first place was to keep the
Titans out even though the real reason
was Carl Fritz's desired to isolate the
island from the rest of the world over
time an entire religion developed around
the walls themselves and this church of
the walls believed that the walls were a
gift from God and had to be protected at
all cost however the truth about the
walls is far different from the
religious doctrine promoted by the
church and everything goes back to the
progenitor Emir fritz the truth about
Emir fritz is difficult to know because
we know at least two completely
different versions according to the
marlins
Emir fritz made a deal with the devil
and she used the titan powers that the
devil allegedly gave her in order to
establish an oppressive and violent
empire that conducted a campaign of
ethnic cleansing against all rival
nations but according to the LDN
restorationist emir Fritz's tightened
powers were a gift from god and she was
a just and benevolent ruler she used her
titan powers to build roads and bridges
and the Audion empire contributed a
great deal to the progress of humanity
as a whole now according to what we've
heard from both the owl
Ehren Kruger and Willie Tiber the 145th
King called Fritz seemed to believe that
the LDN Empire has played a largely
negative role in human history according
to this version of the story carl fritz
felt terrible about all the bad things
that his ancestors had done to other
nations and he made a vow of pacifism he
decided to move as many aliens as he
could behind the walls so that they
could live in peace for as long as
possible but despite making the walls
out of colossal titans and threatening
to use them to destroy the world in case
the island was attacked king fritz
apparently never meant to carry out the
threat again according to this version
of the story king fritz thought that if
one day the Marlins or other nations
decided to attack the island and destroy
all the aliens there he still wouldn't
fight back because the aliens deserved
this fate due to all the terrible things
that they had done in their history and
this is what the 145th king's ideology
allegedly amounts to and this is why
every member of the royal family who
inherits the power of the founding titan
instantly adopts the same pacifist view
and refuses to leave the walls or help
the LD ends of the continent and this
always happens no matter how badly the
person in question wanted to change
things before inheriting the power but
there's just one problem
it doesn't quite add up in chapter 100
we learned from Willie ty berm that the
three walls Maria rose and Sheena were
named after the three daughters of Emir
the original Titan shifter we don't know
much about these daughters although we
do appear to see them on a painted
fresco during the closing credits of the
second attack on Titan anime season the
picture appears to show three young
girls crying while consuming what
appears to be human body parts the girls
are standing over what appears to be the
skeleton of a woman and it is my belief
that this image depicts the death of
Emir Fritz the three girls are her
daughters Maria rose and Sheena and they
are both grieving for their mother and
seemingly consuming parts of her flesh
possibly her spinal fluid in order to
inherit her titan powers so clearly
these three daughters are important the
walls are named after them we see an
image of them in the second sea
and closing credits but we don't know
anything about them at least not yet
if the 145th king called fritz really
believed that the LD and Empire was
terrible and that its sins were so great
that all LD ins deserved to be destroyed
then why name the three walls after the
three daughters of himmier if you think
that he mere Fritz's legacy is a
negative 1 why honor her daughters by
naming the walls after them especially
when the people living within the walls
don't even know about
Ahmir fritz anyway the walls could have
literally just been named wall one wall
2 and wall 3 so I believe that there is
a good reason why they were named after
the daughters of Emir fritz
also if Carl fritz didn't actually
intend to use the colossal Titans within
the walls
why create them in the first place
assuming that there are really millions
of Titans within those walls from
everything we know so far this would
mean that millions of actual people
sacrificed their lives in order to
become those Titans unless there is some
other way to create a Titan that we
still don't know about each one of these
wall Titans is presumably an LD and
human being why go through all that
trouble if you never intended to use
these Titans and you were always going
to just be a pacifist why not fill the
walls with sand and just say that they
are filled with Titans since hardly
anyone from the outside world ever
reaches the walls of the island they
wouldn't know the difference between an
empty threat and a real threat I believe
that the story we've been told about why
Carl Fritz decided to build the walls in
the first place
may not be true and that his pacifist
ideology is not quite what we think if
you think back to the conversation that
Grisha had with the owl
Ehren Kruger before Kruger passed the
attack Titan power onto Grisha you will
recall that Kruger told Grisha to
complete his mission for the sake of
Armin and Mikasa Kruger said this
despite not even knowing who our man
amigas are and of course he couldn't
have known because they hadn't even been
born yet we know that Titan shifters
after they inherit one of the nine titan
powers are able to see the memories of
the previous shifters who were in
possession of that same titan power
which is why Eren is able to see
grisha's memories of his conversation
with Aaron Kruger in the first place but
could it be that inheriting a titan
power not only allows you to see memory
of past Titan shifters but it also
allows you to gain glimpses of the
future through the memories of future
Titan shifters who will hold the same
power as you hold now but sometime later
after all we know that all LD ends are
connected through mysterious paths that
transcend physical space and this is
what allows LD ends to become Titans and
that is also what allows the founding
Titan to manipulate the memories of all
ldiots but what if these paths don't
only transcend space but time as well
the first chapter the manga and the
first episode of the anime are named to
you 2,000 years from now it is as if
Amir fritz who lived some 2,000 years
ago is addressing someone in the present
time we know that when members of the
same family inherit titan powers from
each other those memories will be
clearer than memories that would appear
if someone inherits a titan power from a
complete stranger this is why aaron has
fairly easy access to grisha's memories
but it's not so easy when it comes to
the memories of previous Titan shifters
we also know that royal blood gives the
titan users special abilities and
greater control of his titan powers and
we know that the founding titan power
has been passed on from generation to
generation within the same royal for its
family for 2,000 years
so if Aaron Krueger could see a brief
glimpse of the future by accessing Eren
Yeager's future memories of Mikasa and
Armin isn't it possible that the 145th
King Carl fritz
who had royal blood and access to the
memories of all of his ancestors saw an
even clearer glimpse of a more distant
future in more recent chapters we have
learned that beyond the walls most of
the world hates audience because Marlay
has been using them to fight their Wars
for them there is talk of taking away
all human rights from LD ends because
their ability to turn into Titans makes
other nations see them as inherently
dangerous at the same time we know that
beyond the walls modern weaponry is
advancing rapidly weapons are already
capable of piercing the armored Titans
armor and soon titan powers will become
irrelevant in the face of modern
military technology and weaponry what if
the 145th King saw a glimpse of the
future and he knew that this would
happen and that once titan powers were
no longer effective at warfare
marlee and the rest of the world would
decide that the LD ins are no longer
needed and since their human rights are
being taken away they would eventually
all be eliminated so that their Titan
powers could never pose a threat to
anyone else what if Carl fritz saw a
vision of the future in which the LD n
people faced extinction at the hands of
the other nations and he decided that
the only way to save at least a portion
of the Aldea nation is to isolate it on
the island of parodies behind the three
walls that way even if all the LD ins on
the continent are eliminated at least a
portion of the alienation will survive
on the island of parodies this would
explain why Carl fritz actually created
all those colossal Titans it was not an
empty threat it was an insurance policy
in order to make sure that the cost of
invading the island would be far greater
than any potential reward this would
also explain why Carl Fritz named the
three walls after the three daughters of
Emir he did not think that Aldi in
history was sinful and shameful and he
did not think that the audience deserved
to die because of the sins of their
ancestors rather he respected Aldi in
history he honored the daughters of Emir
by naming the walls after them and his
main goal was to preserve as many LD
ends as possible this would also explain
the 145th Kings ideology and why every
member of the royal family who inherited
the founding titan decided not to
venture beyond the walls and not to help
the LD ends on the continent every
holder of the founding Titan inherits
the vision of the future that Carl fritz
saw and they realized that if they
allowed the LD ends on the island to go
beyond the walls and get involved into
the politics of the outside world this
will inevitably lead to a world war that
will bring about the destruction of all
the ldiots so in order to preserve at
least a portion of the LDN population
each holder of the founding titan is
prepared to sacrifice the other aliens
on the continent this also explains why
Carl Fritz erased the memories of the
outside world from every LDN behind the
walls by erasing their memories of the
outside world
Carl Fritz took away much of the
temptation for LD ends behind the walls
to try to leave as they began to believe
that there was nothing outside the walls
except for deadly Titans the LD ends
behind the walls had very little
motivation to learn about the outside
world and get involved in its affair
which made it less likely that the LD
ends on the island would become involved
in a war with the rest of the world that
would ultimately lead to their
destruction
Carl Fritz wasn't a pacifist because he
believed that the audience deserved to
perish due to the sins of their
ancestors he was a pacifist because he
believed that the only way to save at
least a portion of the Aldea nation from
the wrath of rival nations was to
isolate them and make it too costly for
anyone on the outside to interfere in
their affairs all the subsequent
founding title holders saw things the
same way because they knew that the
audience had no future if they actively
took on the rest of the world and
because resources on the island are
limited and because trying to help the
audience on the continent would lead to
a massive war with marley and
potentially other nations as well every
royal holder of the founding titan power
decided to abandon the other LD ends and
remain as isolated from the outside
world as possible they made this
difficult decision for the sake of
preventing their own nation the LD ins
from going extinct let me know what you
guys think do you agree with my theory
that carl fritz built the walls because
he solved visions of the future which
told him that unless he builds the walls
and seals a segment of the ldm
population behind them the entire LDN
nation would eventually be exterminated
by rival nations using modern weapons
that surpassed the power of the Titans
and if you don't agree why do you think
that he built the walls why do you think
that real Titans were used to make the
walls instead of simply bluffing about
the whole situation
if pacifism was really the Kings true
intention and why do you think that he
named the walls after the three
daughters of Emir if the king allegedly
resented the legacy of Emir Fritz and
the LDN Empire let me know down in the
comments if you enjoyed this video you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell a huge thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for supporting our
work I want to give a special thank you
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh chubs is the
man and nothing but a fan and another
huge thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray a
in grata a Lolan Adam Maddy Mac and
Michael called that on if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]